life at the scp foundation isn't exactly
made up of sunshine and rainbows it's
less of a good vibes kind of place and
more of a this is the solemn work we do
as we stand between humanity in the vast
unfeeling unknowable realm of mystery
and darkness sure sometimes there's a
magic vending machine or a teddy bear
doctor but most of the time the
foundation's findings are a lot more
bite than they are bark thankfully
there's the sea portion of that infamous
acronym contain they keep their bizarre
astounding findings locked up tight
where they can't catch an unsuspecting
innocent off guard and
oh hey there little buddy it's okay you
didn't mean to scare me relax everyone
it's just scp-999
one of the only contained curiosities
allowed to roam freely around the halls
of the foundation just look at this guy
has a sentient mass of translucent
orange slime ever been so cute you want
some chocolate buddy okay here you go
it's incredible really that the place
that houses a neck snapping sculpture in
a haunted chest playing machine could
also be the home of such a delightful
little blob you know now that i think of
it it's amazing that being in the
vicinity of unspeakable horrors day
after day has never put a damper on
999's positive attitude he's got the
persistent cheerful disposition of a
labrador puppy but how well would
scp-999's inherent wholesomeness hold up
against one of the most wicked anomalies
contained by the scp foundation what
would happen if the lightest of the
light a slimy piece of pure goodness
came up against a deep dark evil not the
omnicidal rage of scp-682 we all know
how that went but something quieter well
let's find out
scp-999 was having the best day of its
life to be fair every single day was the
best day of the tickle monster's life
surpassed only by the day that followed
and the one after that and how could it
not be a good life at the scp foundation
when there were so many friends to play
with treats to eat and so much to
explore
scp-999 was enjoying a hearty bowl of m
ms picking out and eating the orange
ones its favorites first when a familiar
figure walked into its pen dr jack
bright who frequently came by to see the
tickle monster when he was having a
disappointing day usually because the
higher-ups had reprimanded him for
breaking the rules yet again
scp-999 cooed delightfully at the sight
of its visitor slithering over to dr
bright and enveloping him in an
enthusiastic hug dr bright immediately
began to laugh as the creature's
euphoric influence took effect hey glad
there are no hard feelings about the
time i ate a piece of you
he giggled as 999 patted his face
affectionately with one of its
pseudo-pods ah thanks that really takes
the sting out of getting the no
chainsaws hammer brought down on me
again he padded the slime with his own
hand in return and satisfied that it had
sufficiently cheered him 999 ooze back
over to its breakfast to finish
consuming the sugary goodness oh i
almost forgot dr bright pulled something
out of his lab coat pocket it was a
small can of cola appealingly shiny in
the white want some
scp-999 gurgled curiously and approached
dr bright to inspect the can he popped
it open with an inviting fizz and
offered some fortunately dr rhodes was
walking by at that exact moment don't
you dare she snatched the can out of her
colleague's hand you remember what
happened last time 999 can't tolerate
caffeine or carbonation dr bright pouted
like a petulant child but i wanted to
see it bounce
do i need to add another rule to the
list dr rhodes crossed her arms or are
you going to behave yourself ugh
fine whatever i'll find something else
to do dr bright rolled his eyes and left
as cp 999's pen with a final friendly
wave of the creature sensing dr rhodes's
stress the tickle monster nuzzled her
leg with an inquisitive gurgle she
smiled indulgently and gave the slime a
hug before she followed dr bright down
the hall keeping an eye out for any more
potentially disruptive antics satisfied
at having cheered everyone up
scp-999 went back to its bowl of candy
and devoured the remaining treats but
then there was nothing left to eat and
no one in the room to visit or play with
what was a lovable slime to do
why explore of course
scp-999 had the freedom to roam all over
the foundation site until bedtime that
is and it loved oozing down the halls
looking for friends to greet and
strangers to meet after all a stranger
is just a friend that the tickle monster
hasn't tickled yet as the slime slid
along the floor it took the time to say
hello to everyone it passed by bumping
them nudging them or in the case of
josie the half cat very gently petting
her head with one of its pseudo pods the
cat purred and 999 responded by
vibrating its gelatinous body producing
a soft purr of its own then josie was
distracted by a dust particle drifting
through a beam of light and darted off
to chase it so the tickle monster
continued on its way looking for
something new and fun to do it spotted
the perfect new activity two guards were
walking into one of the sealed
containment rooms a room that the jolly
little slime had never been inside of
before now was the perfect chance to
investigate and maybe play tickle
wrestling with the guards along the way
it had to act fast though the door was
beginning to close rearranging its body
999 squished itself into a long thin
line sliding quickly through the crack
in the door just before it shot this new
room was very messy much messier than
999 was allowed to keep its own room any
spilled chocolate milk or smeared
cupcake frosting was either cleaned up
by staff or slurped up by the slime
itself but in this room there was thick
black liquid dripping down all of the
walls some of it arranging itself into
patterns and words though 999 couldn't
read what they said the guards hadn't
noticed the tickle monster's presence
yet and it kept still excited to give
them a wonderful surprise when they
turned around and saw that it had
followed them inside but they didn't
turn around they were completely focused
on something in front of them what was
it it was a thick glass case that looked
as if it was about to fall apart at any
moment inside there was a mask a
porcelain mask of a frowning face with
that same strange dark fluid dripping
from its eye and mouth holes you know
the procedure right one guard said he
was holding a brand new glass case shiny
and completely empty
of course i do the other scoffed it's my
first time with this anomaly not my
first day on the job just open it up and
take the mask out and put it in here he
tapped on the case he was holding as
quickly as possible yeah i just said i
know the less experienced guard grumbled
don't patronize me he reached towards
the decaying case and prepared to unlock
it wait did you hear that hear what i
thought i heard
never mind
scp-999 vibrated with excitement would
they give it some well-deserved
attention maybe play a game but no the
guard wasn't talking about the eager
orange pal behind him he was feeling the
influence of something much more
sinister do you want me to do it the
more experienced guard offered no just
you really don't hear that that
whispering his colleague just shook his
head
fine it's just been a long week i guess
he signed and popped the case open
reaching for the mask inside as soon as
his fingers made contact with the
porcelain surface the black goo dripping
onto his skin where he should have been
wearing protective gloves his expression
shifted his eyes went blank like someone
sleepwalking lost in a dream even as
their body moved in the waking world
frank what are you waiting for the other
guard nudged him but frank said nothing
he delicately lifted the mask out of the
glass box and before anyone could stop
him place the frowning white face over
his own only it wasn't frowning anymore
as soon as its features slipped over
frank's covering him erasing him its
mouth curved into a malicious smile
frank what the hell are you doing the
guard cried out as the man he had once
known grabbed hold of his shoulders not
frank anymore
a voice came out from behind the ceramic
lips but it was different cruel cold
ancient frank's gone out i'm afraid and
he won't be back anytime soon
the guard tried to break away from the
masked man's grasp tried to reach for
the emergency alarm to signal that the
containment change had gone horribly
wrong but the mask shoved him into the
wall hard the guard hit his head and
slumped to the ground unconscious and
likely concussed well
scp-999 has had just about enough of all
this it hated seeing anyone hurt
especially humans and clearly its help
was sorely needed to make things better
it couldn't tell exactly what had upset
the man in the mask so much that he was
acting this way but he knew one thing
that always cheered humans up it was
time for a bit of good old-fashioned
tickle wrestling
scp-999 hurled itself across the room
enveloping frank's body from his feet to
his neck and it began tickling him as it
did the force of 999's tackle sent
frank's body careening towards the
ground and when it landed with a heavy
thud the mask flew off his face and
skittered across the floor now that i
could see frank's face 999 looked for
signs of laughter of joy but frank was
dead asleep eyes closed jaw slack his
heart was still beating but he wouldn't
wake up confused concerned and upset at
what it had witnessed in this new room
the slime slithered along the floor
toward the mask that had caused so much
trouble it seemed to be staring at 999
with its dark vacant eyes it didn't look
like a toy in fact it looked like
something that the slime should avoid
touching but it couldn't help but notice
that the face had changed back to a
frown could 999 really leave the mask
there on the floor frowning like that
the tickle monster couldn't help it with
a soft greeting by way of a high-pitched
cooing noise it reached out to the mask
and picked it up though the slime
creature didn't have a traditional face
for the mask to sit on top of its
influence quickly grabbed hold of 999's
gelatinous frame it stopped moving
stopped gurgling stopped looking at the
world through rose-colored glasses right
now
scp-999 was being piloted by the
possessive mask and it was looking for a
way out once it escaped containment it
could find a new host a proper host with
arms legs and a mouth but for now this
undignified vehicle would have to do it
took the mask some time to learn how to
pilot this strange soft body with its
malleable form and the odd methods of
moving itself around the room but it
slowly adjusted and wearing the
silhouette of the tickle monster like a
disguise oozed out of its containment
room and into the hall staff walking by
barely even noticed 999's presence they
were too preoccupied with their work
they were used to seeing it and giving
it a polite nod but most of them didn't
have the time to stop and say a proper
hello at this time of day perhaps this
would be easy after all the mask had
lost its chosen host but found something
even better the perfect cover and the
chance to hide in plain sight it could
take in the lay of the land scope out
potential exit routes and ideally slide
out of foundation custody completely
unnoticed the mask began to smile at the
thought as the mask steered scp-999's
body around the site a peculiar feeling
began to nod the back of its mind like
an itch it couldn't quite scratch
something irritating that wouldn't leave
it alone what was that feeling inside of
its own consciousness the mask heard a
sound a sweet high-pitched gurgle no
that was impossible and yet somehow the
consciousness of the tickle monster had
survived in the face of the mask's power
it was there still needling at the
mask's darkness with that insipid
insistent kindness shut up the mask is
frowning this body belongs to me now why
won't you just die
another gurgle this one even louder more
difficult to shut out did this infernal
thing ever shut up the mask stopped
moving for a moment concentrating the
force of its will it would drive
scp-999's mind away and re-establish
dominance just as the mask was grappling
with the influence of scp-999 however a
familiar figure turned down the hall it
was dr rhodes from earlier
scp-999's exuberance bubbled up to the
surface and the mask couldn't stop its
mouth from flipping back to a smile what
no that was ridiculous and yet the
longer the mask was in contact with the
vibrant orange slime so delighted by
every familiar and unfamiliar face it
encountered it could feel that horrible
positive influence growing stronger and
stronger it was a nauseating warm fuzzy
feeling that just made him want to the
mask let out a giggle then another and
before long it was in the midst of an
absolute giggling fit the mask had
laughed before it had laughed plenty of
times but it was usually a mocking laugh
a cackle of triumph this was a giggle
though of pure joy the sort of sound a
small child makes as they chase a
butterfly through a field this was the
sound of innocence of happiness it was
love
now you listen to me you vile little
worm the mass growled it wasn't certain
if 999 could even understand it but it
had to show this rebellious creature who
was really in charge release your drip
on me i have won you have lost your form
is mined in you
nothing more than a puppet for me to
pull on your strings and use you to my
own ends show some respect and defer
to
me
the voice of the slime creature
whimpered in the mask's mind a sound
like a chastised puppy slinking away
with its tail between its legs
that's more like it the mask huffed dr
rhodes looked up from her clipboard and
spotted scp-999
she waved about to greet the creature
when she noticed the horrible mask
perched on top she dropped her clipboard
in shock gasping at the site no she
breathed hard sinking as she saw one of
the purest pieces of good in all of the
foundation fall into the forces of the
mask that's right
the mask would have puffed out its chest
if this body had a chest to puff i've
taken a new host do you like my
selection
it relished the tearful look in the
woman's eyes the horror that caused her
hands to shake and her cheeks to go pale
show me the way to the exit so i might
take my leave of this place and perhaps
i will spare your life the mask was just
gearing up for a good threat a really
nightmarish one filled with vivid
descriptions of mutilation and violence
when that disgusting feeling began to
rise up again that warmth that buoyancy
it made the mask want to please don't be
sad here let me give you a hug before it
could stop itself the mask slithered the
tickle monster's body over to dr rhodes
wrapping around her tightly not to hurt
her no to embrace her to comfort her her
horror turned to laughter as the mood
lifting effect of 999's presence began
to work its magic through her laughter
she was also confused why why
she couldn't finish the question but it
was enough to break the mask out of the
spell it reared back horrified at its
actions what have i done what have i
done it slithered quickly down the hall
around the corner away from that woman
who had evoked such fond feelings
towards her no
towards all of humanity the mask steered
its body into a bathroom coming face to
face with a mirror it stared at its
reflection its familiar face and dark
eyes dripping their usual fluid perched
atop this alien thing poisoning its mind
what did you do to me what sort of magic
is this of course 999 did not answer but
the mask could feel its presence could
feel its delight in the impact it was
having you're ruining me the mass
groaned i strike terror into hearts i
drive men to madness i render their
sanity into i
it trailed off overwhelmed again by the
urge to smile to laugh to frolic though
it didn't have a working nose the mask
could swear it smelled an array of
heavenly scents of fresh roses breaking
bed in a stone oven vanilla and lightly
burnt brown sugar it reached for itself
with its pseudo-pods about to tear
itself off of the slimy body altogether
but it paused ah
very clever
i see what your game is
it lowered the pseudo-pods brimming with
determination you won't trick me into
sparing your life once i found my
freedom and host worthy of me i will
destroy you
once and for all
but even as the mask made this
declaration the black liquid seeping
from its eyes and mouth began to change
to take on a lighter appearance was it a
trick of the light no it was it was
orange like the gelatinous flesh of the
horde creature it had made the mistake
of attaching to no matter how hard the
mask fought the influence of scp-999 was
spreading its mind raced trying to come
up with a new plan a way to hold on to
its identity but the sound of an alarm
blaring outside the bathroom spurred it
to get a move on once more clearly dr
rhodes had alerted someone that the mask
had reached containment time was running
out it needed to find the exit fast it
was now or never the mask oozed back
into the hall speeding up as it went
trying desperately to find a way out
before whatever transformation had begun
could complete itself but even as it
struggled he could feel itself changing
warping it burst into giggles again and
whistled a happy tune it stopped running
for a moment to wave at an armed guard
and blow them a kiss why had it wanted
to leave this facility in the first
place everyone here was so kind was so
lovely was its best friend no no must
resist must not give into the optimism
to the happiness to the goodness if the
mask had teeth it would have been
clenching them trying to stem the tide
of joyful noises that threatened to
burst out it felt like something was
tickling it and the tickling just
wouldn't stop stop it the mask dissolved
into giggles again i mean it it could
feel something coming something big a
loud cracking sound rang out and just as
the guards were closing in on the
possessed tickle monster they watched in
awe as cracks spread across the surface
of the possessive mask and all at once
it shattered into pieces the pieces fell
to the floor where they pulled
themselves back together with strands of
black goop meanwhile scp-999 sat there
bouncing with glee completely unharmed
the tickle monster received an extra
special ice cream sundae for its bravery
and amazing work and the mask was
returned to its containment chamber in a
brand new glass case as the mask
suffered an identity crisis for the
first time in its existence
scp-999 curled up in its pen full of
sugar and gratitude and got some
well-deserved rest now go check out
scp-999 tickle monster versus the most
evil scps and the whole story what if
scp-096 wore
scp-035 for more stories of the tickle
monster and the possessive mask